bore on the floor
hey
okay it's a game in the corner
over there stand there go go go go
all right
tom me yeah uh pierced yeah
um well that's a lot of
factors and but
yes i personally i like it i like it
bore on the floor over there
jerry stand up stand up
pierce couldn't tell you don't know have
you played it before no
well actually i to be perfectly honest
i've had a few doubts
honesty you see everybody do you see
honesty greg stand up
did you get any orders from my brother
the conscience of the prairies
me yeah i don't
uh yeah
i could i think i've had some doubts too
oh
doubter over there but the rules
are that you're spared if you tell the
truth and i just told you the truth oh
there are rules right do you know
something greg
there are no rules
over there okay
roman i like it for real dad
the up um
okay
kendall took a call from the biographer
we all got a call rome
okay yes but you see he seemed like he
wanted to actually talk to her
to smoke you out for dad what you
why do you get to smoke me out i was
smoking you out
why did you tell us about your mystery
call the phone call
uh yeah it was frank he meant to call
you he wants to know if the plan
overthrow dad is still happening
someone spiked pierce
which one of you boys did it tom
yes sit on the floor it's fun
seriously yeah it's a game bore on the
floor i really i
feel get down bore on the floor
bore on the floor kendall ring the
troops boy
on the floor
greg on the floor or on the floor
come on fry on the floor pranks
how the would i know greg you think
i have a wrestling explanation for this
frank
feed the piggies guest of honor
[Applause]
oink for your sausages piggy i i oh
jesus christ
wait for your sustenance tom oink
on the count of three the last piggy
to eat a sausage is the mole that
doesn't seem like a very good system
who spoke to pencil please
hey crawl in a circle and close your
eyes
three greg oink
two
i got it
[Music]
[Applause]
effing slow i'll get you here booby
price
eat up piggies i believe he said eat up
piggies
i want to see you little piggy eat
eat it indemnification dummy
serious how old are you give me
back your phone
what are you hiding what are you hiding
nothing giving my phone
are you serious my code uh my
code is um
what oh still wait face clock
you're gonna you stick okay
you got it all right
happy there's nothing in there
you